burying their dead
families in afghanistan's bar mall
district prepare the final resting place
for their loved ones
more than a thousand people have been
killed by a powerful earthquake the
worst to hit the country in 20 years
the damage is extensive for many the
loss is immeasurable
it has destroyed the houses of our
neighbors when we arrived there were
many dead and wounded they sent us to
the hospital i also saw many dead bodies
nearby desperate families use their
hands and anything they can find to
search for survivors
delivering aid to affected areas is
challenging
we are facing some difficulties we've
had some unseasonal rain in the last few
days and we know already that there are
landslides that are blocking some roads
so that is certainly going to hamper
efforts
hundreds of people are injured in the
provinces of patkya and coast where
access to hospitals and medicine is
limited
people in these remote regions near the
border with pakistan are still
struggling to recover from the war
and now another tragedy
most aid agencies and international
support organizations pulled out of
afghanistan when the taliban took
control in august last year
an economic crisis was already fueling a
humanitarian catastrophe statistics by
various agencies suggest that over
nearly 60 percent of the country was uh
people were suffering from poverty
before we came to power so it has only
compounded the difficulties
and that is mainly due to the sanctions
and the acid freeze
and the callous behavior of the
international communities
while the full extent of the damage is
yet to be known it's already clear that
the recovery will take years
katya lopez
al jazeera